one of the things he made about the
Fertile Crescent where the original
since the first cities took shape is
later referred to as the fragile
Crescent because basically climate
instability in that area and how does a
fragile Crescent play out in terms of
cities so the idea of you know we all
grew up with the Mesopotamia is the the
Fertile Crescent hilly flanks to the
Fertile Crescent which made it sound
like it was this ideal place for a
cities to come up and then all the
archaeologists who went to work there
and said oh god it's really hot and it's
like it's drought the farmers keep
losing their crops and it burns and so
on this is not fertile this is awful
so it's an archaeologist Tony Wilkinson
and his group who came up with the idea
with a fragile Crescent Oh
now that's really interesting because it
suggests that cities come up not in
places that are really wonderful but in
cities in places that have some kind of
problem right so immediately you think
of something like New Orleans right New
Orleans probably really ought not to
still exist but people just keep going
back and mopping it up because it has
something that overcomes that liability
so maybe cities thrive and survive
because they are inherently dependent on
creativity to exist at all I think
that's a really wild idea you know that
with that synergy of creativity is what
makes cities persist if you think about
in the last thousand years there is not
a single city that has been abandoned
except for maybe Chernobyl